[Music]
all these different aspects of
meditation are designed to get us to
think about who god is as we think about
that we we see what we want to become
like
right and we see what he's trying to do
have you ever wondered what is true
biblical meditation
find out on this episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness
well welcome everyone to led live we are
here for another program this is a
second part in a series on meditation
and today we're going to look at
what is true biblical meditation
compared to all of those what is that
really like and so we have a couple of
guests with us today we have eric wilson
it's good to see you and we have mike
shreve great to be back with mike
you know
experts and things of their past and and
now hopefully more experts in the things
of the word
and so we're going to talk about this
now i don't know if we want to go here
first but you did say you wanted to
explain something from the last program
yes i did and if i didn't bring it out
in this program then uh people would
still be waiting for an answer in that
particular area so because the last of
eight kinds of meditation which is
actually the basis of something called
contemplative prayer
and that's a huge movement
in
christianity right now especially in
nominal churches many of whom
don't necessarily teach the experience
of being born again they're still hungry
for the supernatural sure they're still
reaching for spiritual fulfillment and
so they're grasping yeah and now they've
gone into this
semi-eastern approach
called contemplative prayer which really
much of the terminology in that movement
is yogic or
hindu approaches to meditation
dressed up in christian terminology but
it's the same kind of approach like for
instance the jesus prayer have you ever
heard of the jesus prayer uh i believe
i've got it written down here somewhere
is it our father which art in heaven
where you're supposed to just over and
over again hundreds of times all day
long say something like lord jesus
christ
uh i am a sinner forgive me lord jesus
it's something similar to that uh i
don't have the exact wording but it's
basically taking a phrase and repeating
it over and over and over a mantra yeah
it is yeah and and it's called the jesus
prayer which had been practiced by
uh many monks and many christians who uh
believe in that kind of approach but
jesus said use not vain repetitions like
the heathen do and then they also talk
about silent meditation
and i've always
heard them quote out of psalm 46 when
they talk about silent meditation
and one of the main proponents of silent
meditation is a man named thomas burton
who was a catholic monk
and he was also
very much
intertwined with buddhist thought to the
point where he said i see no
contradiction between buddhism and
christianity wow that's terrible
he said i intend to be as good a
buddhist as i can wow buddhists do not
accept a creator god
they believe in cause and effect
and of course there's plenty of things
that are taught in christianity that
disagree with buddhism and vice versa
for instance buddha taught that we do
not have a soul
that there's five parts to a human being
that disassembled it death
and
buddha also taught that believing you
have some kind of eternal existence in
heaven is a hindrance to meditation
and that it's not true and so
there
there's quite a big conflict between
what thomas merton taught about buddhism
and the reality of the matter so so the
big kind of like
phrase that we hear over and over again
is be still and know that i am god oh
yeah yeah i need that yeah i wanted to
say that that was what was taken from
psalms right because if i don't get into
that now we'll probably forget about
bringing it out
people use that as a basis for proving
that god wants us to be silent in
meditation just sit there for long
periods of time completely silent still
in your mind which i don't believe is
relational i don't believe that brings
you into relationship with god and
they'll quote that scripture psalm 46
verse 10 be still and know that i am god
but you've got to know the context of
any scripture in order to really
understand what's being said right
it's called contextual
interpretation and when you go to the
context
it's not about meditation it's not even
about prayer
it's about the final judgment of this
earth where god wipes out
uh the the armies of the earth it says
come behold the works of the lord
who has made desolations in the earth he
makes wars cease to the end of the earth
he breaks the bow and cuts the spear
into he burns the chariot in the fire
which is a symbolic way of saying nation
shall not lift up sword against nation
because he's going to crush all
of this type of activity at the coming
of the lord when he brings the kingdom
of god to this earth it will devastate
the the
cultural approach to conflict which is
war mike you know what
right there right after he says that he
burneth the chariot in the fire then he
says be still and know that i am god
it's like you guys can't do anything i
mean like man thinks we're so great and
god's like watch what i can do with a
snowstorm yeah and
and i think there's two ways to
interpret that first he's saying be
still and know that i am god in other
words when you see the last days
approaching and you know it's going to
be a time of great persecution and
conflict just be calm about it amen he's
not saying meditate in silence for an
hour he's saying just become i'm god
i am the beginning in the end i started
this thing i will end it with victory
this is a great biblical concept that i
just want to hang here for just one
second because satan used the very words
of god's
writing in the bible to try and and get
jesus to false that's a great point so
you can't just take one phrase out of it
just because it's in the bible hey it
was in the bible you have to look at the
context of that and you have to see why
i was just said what was it said what's
before what's after it to understand
what that means yeah and also that could
be interpreted as god's speaking
to the resistance to the antichrist and
all the beast government that fills the
earth to try and bring it into one world
government god could be saying you just
be still yeah you've lifted your voices
you've tried to bring the earth under
your influence i'm god
now it's interesting because i have
heard this phrase in christianity but
i've never heard it in that context yeah
you you hear that come out all the time
and it's always spoken of you need to be
still and listen to what god's going to
tell you that's the context that they're
saying it in
well
is that wrong is it wrong to be still
yes and no
it depends on what your motives are and
maybe you can kind of bring that out as
you show us what you've got on the
screen here what mike was sharing about
what we looked at in our last program on
the hindu and the buddhists and the
taoist meditations
those things are now being repackaged
they're being given new names and
they're being brought into the church
they're being infiltrated as if you can
christianize paganism
i'm just going to go real quickly here
and show you a couple of books from some
of the men that are doing this
the book on the left
it says why did jesus moses the buddha
cross the road
as if jesus the buddha and moses all
were on the same level and muhammad and
muhammad that's right
so it
brian mclaren when he wrote this he was
equating all of them as equals
matthew fox wrote a book called one
river many wells so it's almost like
there's many paths that are leading to
the final you know to
heaven another book befriending the
silence by carl malcolm
befriending the silence it's like
welcoming this experience of of the
silence
matthew fox christian mystics 365
readings and meditations like a
devotional of mysticism
here we go thomas merton
seeds of contemplation which i believe
was one of his earlier books and then
he's got another one called come into
the silence right and this man a lot of
people that go into seminary and also
into religious classes and universities
their professors are giving these books
as recommended reading
and they're falling under the influence
but i don't believe
men like thomas merton or thomas keating
who was also a leader in the
contemplative movement
ever really had a genuine born-again
experience i agree i don't think they
knew jesus which is sad and
heartbreaking because they were very
devoted to
a religious approach and a a seeking
mindset
but
they they say things when you read their
writings that legitimize other
approaches that legitimize buddhism and
hinduism as if and this is the basis of
contemplative prayer
that the spirit of god is already within
every human being so to look for god you
look within which is a basic new age
principle right and
that's not where you find god i'm
fascinated with with
the titles that they gave them because
you think of seeds when they go into the
ground when a plant comes up it's very
actually hard to distinguish what that
plant is sometimes the plant has to get
bigger and the leaves have to actually
get developed before you can go aha i
know where that is and so calling your
book the seeds of contemplation sounds
like you know something that might not
be harmful but that plant grows up to
its fruition and it may kick you off
course by their fruits you shall know
them i like how god puts things in his
words because you know here we we think
we have to do these you know take these
long periods of silence or or ask
something multiple times in a row and
god is much more simplistic that than
that says in first john 5 he says now
this is the confidence that we have in
him if we ask anything according to his
will he hears us amen done you ask once
god hears you you know if it's according
to his bill
let's do it and then in the gospels
jesus says if you then being evil know
how to give good gifts to your children
how much more will you heavenly father
give the holy spirit to those that
ask him he just said just just ask me
and he actually even knows before we ask
we don't even know where what we need to
ask for yet and god already and to
reduce it to something mechanical
is an insult to god
to chant a mantra to say over and over
again the jesus prayer whatever the
correct wording is lord jesus christ son
of god have mercy on me a sinner
amen uh
you don't have to say to your wife
something like please fix um
uh squash goulash for dinner a thousand
times for her to do it yeah one time is
enough right yeah that would be like if
if my son or my daughter desperately
needed toothpaste
and so in order to gain me to go get the
toothpaste for him they had to come in
as little children and bow and say a
thousand times please give us toothpaste
in a monotone way right
in your life this way but see that's
what happens when we separate god from
being a father right all of a sudden he
is he's just a force yeah that needs to
be manipulated with the right
incantation or the right mechanical kind
of esoteric process
and that's not what god what's the realm
of of the action in your hands meaning
like just because of what you did this
was the result rather than when we come
to god it's it's it's all god he's the
one that's doing it we're petitioning
our requests before him but he
ultimately has the ability to say yes or
no
rather than i just did this and this and
this and this now i'm making him
do this and he tells us how to approach
him in psalm 100 it says enter his gates
with thanksgiving
and enter his course with praise that's
all communication it's not repetitious
ritualistic or mantra-like you enter his
gates thanking him for life and breath
and thanking him for the blessings that
are in your life thanking him for the
promises of god fulfilled and then you
enter into praise where you're just
praising god because he's god
and in psalm 22 it says god inhabits the
praises of these people he doesn't
inhabit the silence amen
it's also interesting peter's experience
when jesus asked him the same question
three times like peter was in anguish by
the time yeah just asking three times
you're like do you what's good to your
wife
you know here jesus by the third time
he's like what else do i gotta do you
know
he's just like i'm done it's like you
know all he really needed is ask once
you know and he knew that but he was
really driving a point home by the third
time i mean it's enough the point was
done it was driven
at this point well anyway
i think i think we've covered pretty
sufficiently
that
entering the silence is not necessarily
entering the presence of god because
entering the presence of god is
relational it's an infilling it's
experiential you sense his presence his
love his power
and that's not going to be waiting for
you
when you finally achieve a place of
complete silence in your mind
necessarily
you may have mystical experiences that
mislead you by doing that that doesn't
mean silence is wrong i see you've got
another cover there thomas keating and
i've read a lot of thomas keating's
quotes and just shake my head
realizing that he's trying to make an
amalgamation of hinduism and buddhism
and christianity all into one
let me if you don't care let me share
just a couple of quotes here from some
other
names that you might be familiar with i
know our listeners this is a pastor
named rob bell and this is from a sermon
that he did back in 2005
and listen to what he says this went out
to millions of people
he said central to the christian
tradition for thousands of years now
what he doesn't tell you there is that's
roman catholic mysticism right
he says it's christian tradition
not biblical
for thousands of years have been
disciplines of meditation reflection
silence and breathing you can't find
that in the bible no you can find it in
the mystical stuff of the desert fathers
or whoever or the book of acts you can't
you can't find how the early church
functioned that way
he says and the yoga masters say that
this is how it is when you follow jesus
and surrender to god the yoga masters
yeah
now listen listen to this he said now
from way back
when our ancestors understood that
there's something divine about our
breath and that's what you were talking
about earlier right in the last show
they believe that there's something
sacred and holy about the very act of
breathing now listen to what he ends
with
i wonder sometimes when we feel as
though god is far away
that god is thinking i gave you
breathing i can't get closer
that's what is being taught in many of
our churches yeah and the breath that is
in our lungs is not the breath of god we
we covered that in the last session
how uh people get the two mixed together
yes but breathing
exercises and silent meditation
accompanying breathing exercises was
something i did in yoga all the time
because we believe that the breath was
permeated with prana and prana is
supposed to be that elemental life force
that uh fills everything right and so by
breathing you're intensifying your
experience of prana and becoming more
one with god and self-aware
but
that's not the breath of god when jesus
stood in the upper room and breathed on
the disciples and said receive the holy
spirit that was not something they had
it was something they didn't have they
did not have the breath of god and he
breathed it into them and that's
completely different than the breath
that is gaseous vapors from the
atmosphere
yes in the very text itself it it says
how that happened he breathed upon them
it wasn't that they just took a deep
breath you know what i mean like you
just read the verse like it is that's
right so it's much different let me read
one one last quote this is from uh a
teacher and he's also from the catholic
faith uh his name is basil pennington he
said
we should not hesitate to take the fruit
of the age-old wisdom of the east you
know it's funny because i believe in the
book of james i think it's in james it
says this wisdom descendeth not from
above but is from beneath it's sensual
it's devilish
he says we should take this age-old
wisdom of the east and capture it for
christ like christ needs that
indeed those of us who are in ministry
should make the necessary effort to
acquaint ourselves with as many of these
eastern techniques as possible when
that's terrifying that is terrible when
god asked the israelites to turn their
backs to the east was it no he asked
yeah their backs were to be to the east
yeah their backs to the east is it
because of the eastern influences he was
based no that was where the sun rose
and
it actually talks about that i believe
in ezekiel where it says i saw the
elders of israel and they had their face
toward the sun worshiping and god was
like i don't want you worshiping towards
the sun because he knew that's it's an
easy
trick for the enemy to start getting you
worshipping the sun the sun god yeah the
other thing that's interesting too is if
you look at i think yeah i just pulled
it up first kings
uh chapter four it says that solomon's
wisdom
exceeded
all the wise men of the east oh wow i
forgot about that or was it daniel
this is solomon it's first kings four
solomon's wisdom excelled the wisdom of
all the men of the east and all the
wisdom of egypt pagan cultures right
god's wisdom when he asked god you know
this i want an understanding heart so i
can judge your people
god says okay you're going to excel you
know above all that and and i think it's
true for daniel too here he is you know
he spent yeah
three years in battlefront you know
and yeah much much wiser so
if you really want wisdom and you really
want understanding it's not we don't
find it amen we find it in the word
right absolutely
and and when
god explained in deuteronomy that they
were not to involve themselves in
various occult practices like necromancy
or contacting the dead or a sorcery or
witchcraft
and then he went on to explain that that
was why
he destroyed the canaanite nations it
was because they were immersed in false
occultic religious practices that were
open doors to demon possessions he says
it was for your good always yeah yeah
so
does that mean we throw the baby out
with the bath water and we never
meditate
is that the right response
or is there a true biblical meditation
well
define meditation you're talking about
just
thinking about contemplating the things
that that you know god would say you
read a verse
you know you're mulling it over in your
head
well i like the word mulling yeah
because that kind of you're chewing on
him right which is actually the essence
of the meaning of the word meditation it
means rumination
which is what a cow knows when it chews
the cut interesting it will chew the
grass and then swallow it down into one
of its stomachs and then up chuck it
again and chew it a little more and test
it a little bit here and puke it up
again and chew it a little bit more and
eventually it
turns into milk
can i does that make you want to have a
glass of milk can i interject something
yeah this is so cool
what you just said ruminating this did
not even hit me do you know that in the
bible
the word for god's law in hebrew is
torah right when you look up its
definition in hebrew it means the first
definition i believe is to flow like
water
the root of that word means
to graze like an ox or cattle grazing on
the grass
so ruminating
actually is what like that's the word
meditation it means chewing
my word and and my instructions and to
the process of eating and your mother
told you not to swallow your food fast
amen if you're going to get the full
nutritional content you need to chew
what do they say 20 times i don't think
i'd do that
but everybody you're supposed to chew
about 20 times and that way
part of the digestive process goes on in
your mouth before you swallow it that
means even even with god's word i don't
need a quickie i don't need a happy meal
oh yeah blah blah blah i read 10 verses
boom i'm gone yeah i need to sit down
and even if you only take two verses or
one verse meditate and chew on that and
say god
make me understand this well really
i've got
several passages of scripture
that really lead us that way but first i
want to quote psalm 19 verse 14 where
david said let the words of my mouth and
the meditation of my heart be acceptable
in your sight o lord my strength and my
redeemer
and that leads me to believe therefore
that there are meditation practices that
are not acceptable that treat god like
some kind of cosmic force
that you almost have to manipulate with
the right kind of esoteric approach
also psalm 104
verses 33-34
says i will sing to the lord as long as
i live i will sing praise to my god
while i have my being
may my meditation of him
be sweet to him
i will be glad in the lord and the
complete jewish bible translating that
same
phrase says may my musings be pleasing
to him so there's three things here
identifying what kind of meditation we
should be practicing number one it's got
to be acceptable
number two it's got to be sweet to god
and number three it should be pleasing
well i don't think to go back to what
we've discussed some repeated phrase
over and over again is sweet
you wouldn't tell your wife that comes
to you and stands in your face and then
a monotone voice says please take out
the garbage please take out the garbage
and she says it 100 or 200 times
before you go get the can and take it
out to the road
that wasn't very sweet
sweetness comes when there's a flow of
genuine emotion and feeling and
worshipfulness and adoration attached to
it
and then it's pleasing
and then it is acceptable do you know
what i have found i had a i had an older
man of god years ago when i first got
pulled out of the darkness and he he
said something to me one time
i was struggling with with numerous sins
in my life strongholds
and
i asked him i said i just can't seem to
get victory in this area of my life and
he asked me a question got real quiet he
said and we were on the phone i never
met him in person
he said eric he said
when you pray do you pray out loud or do
you pray in your head or no first he
said
when you read your bible do you read it
out loud or do you read in your head i
said in my head
and he said okay he said when you pray
do you pray out loud or do you pray in
your head
and i said in my head and then he said
why
and i thought that's a weird question
and i said i don't want the devil
hearing me
and then he answered
i'll never forget he said
do you think the one you're praying to
has less power than the one you're
afraid of
and i was like
man if my little boy had three guys at
school that were going to beat him up
you think he would come and say daddy i
need your help because he's scared of
them hearing him cry for help
he'd go dad i need your help and this
man told me that so when when i'm
reading god's promises out loud and i'm
reading my name into the promise
it's praising god and it's also
empowering me because his spirit is is
filling me with god's power and his
presence that's absolutely right and
besides the devil is not omnipresent
amen he can't be with every christian
all the time
when there's 2 billion professing
christians in the world satan can't be
in 2 billion different places at once
so i think to kind of bring it a little
bit closer to home as well you know how
you i don't know if you guys have ever
experienced this but you get into a
habit of you pray before your meals
right yeah okay when i went into the
world my prayer before my meals ceased
like you know i didn't i remember eating
many years lots of meals never said a
prayer for him or whatsoever
but then i came back into the church
really started developing a relationship
with god and it's like you get in this
kind of little rut of the same prayer
the same thing for the meal and it's
sort of this impersonal but you do it
anyway because it's like what you're
supposed to do you know i just don't
imagine that's how god wants us to pray
to him you know it's almost like that's
not really doing anything that you're
saying it just for the sake of saying it
yeah and i've tried to be purposeful
about that even when i you know when i
pray with my kids before night it's like
you know make that prayer genuine like
jesus is in the room and you're talking
to him as a friend amen and jesus
jesus refers to this scripture
where it says out of the mouths of babes
and succulents you have perfected praise
perfect praise is not polished
it's not practiced it's not professional
it isn't that rigid religious kind of
approach it's spontaneous and it's
heartfelt
and so i agree with you every time we
pray over meals i try to say it a little
bit different
and that's the way it should be so how
do we meditate as christian because
we're not going to throw the baby out
with the bath water there is a correct
way to meditate right
and the first place i want to go to is
meditating on god's word
which is the emphasis actually in
scripture
and joshua 1 8 is a great beginning
point this is where god himself spoke to
joshua and said
this book of the law shall not depart
from your mouth amen you brought out
that point
i've found that when i read the word of
god out loud i actually get more
revelation more inside than when i read
it
in silence mike you know it's
interesting and this didn't click until
you just said that
this book of the law shall not depart
out of your mouth
jesus said
like king david
thy word thy law have i hid in my heart
jesus said out of the heart
the abundance of the mouth or all the
abundance of the heart the mouth speaks
so the more that we hide his word in our
heart the more is going to come out of
our mouth not only in conversation with
others but our conversation with god
amen thank you lord we we
present his word back to him
not to manipulate god not to force his
hand not to say now god you said it in
your words you've got to do it but in a
worshipful stance god i thank you for
giving me this promise amen because it's
more it's more about
you actually hearing those when you
praise god he he knows what he's done
he's god he doesn't need you to validate
god
it's when we sit there and we say those
praises out loud we're sitting there
going yeah look god man you've provided
this awesome house for me wow god
there's always food on my table wow you
know and you're recognizing
god is amazing he's taken care of my
whole life we need to hear that i
believe sometimes as well and so god's
asking us to verbalize that i'm i'm
learning now to do that more it's like
people will say to me well when i pray
how do you know you're going to get what
you pray for well i say well i find
where god's promised that he'll give it
to me because he can't lie right so i
find a promise and then i say lord
i'm asking you for this you know the
best time for it to show up you've
promised it to me so i know it's on the
way so now all i have to do is start
thanking you so as i'm thanking him it's
not because he selfishly is i got to
have praise
he's just wanted me to praise him
because it's voicing my faith that his
word can't fail
my father was converted through that
process
my father and i had kind of a
tension in our relationship after i was
born again
to the point where he asked me he said
if you come home don't bring religion
with you he was a good man a man of
great honesty and integrity and morality
but he just didn't accept some biblical
things
and for 12 years i prayed with him my
mother who was one of my first converts
to the lord after i found jesus uh she
and i fasted for him sought god in his
behalf then one day he developed a neck
condition where his head was
frozen in a
position like this if he 88 with his
head bowed if he talked he had to talk
to you this way he finally checked into
the hospital he was laying there with
his head about he called me later that
night and said mike
i was already in the right position
i figured i might as well pray i said
that was a subtle hint from heaven
wasn't it
he said i decided i was going to thank
god for every good thing he'd ever done
in my life amen and it took him two
hours
amen he's not even born again yet and he
takes two hours he was
he he was he kept books
he had retired from the navy and he was
uh like a cpa
or something similar and so he had that
kind of mind of details and so he went
from the earliest years
of his life and went through every
blessing every benefit and finally he
said i ran out of things to thank god
for so i decided to praise god because
he's god
and i said dad that's a biblical
principle amen some 100. that's how we
approach god you don't go into the
silence you go into the throne room with
praise amen and he said i don't know
about all that all i know is while i was
praising god all of a sudden and my my
father was a man of great integrity he
never would have fabricated something
like this
he said all of a sudden a golden light
came in the hospital room the face of
jesus appeared in the light
and
suddenly the golden light turned to a
crimson red and waves of red light
started pouring over him and he said i
knew i was being bathed in the blood of
jesus and i knew i was being born again
and for the next month all he could do
was weep and cry every time you talk to
him he'd break down weeping with
gratitude not sorrow but with gratitude
and thankfulness toward god so
he had an encounter with god by doing it
the bible way amen but let let me break
this down a little bit more joshua 1 8
as you said the word law represents the
torah in the hebrew it's the word torah
which is the first five books of the
bible genesis exodus leviticus numbers
and deuteronomy
i believe you could expand this to all
66 books amen where god would say this
entire word of god shall not depart from
your mouth but you shall meditate in it
day
and night which implies every waking
moment amen you're dwelling on the word
you're letting it guide your actions
your reactions your interactions with
other people when you're in prayer or
when you're in conversations with other
human beings and many other bible
passages exhort us to meditate on the
word of god
and i've got a few here you might be
able to pull them up
psalm 119 verse 97 says oh how i love
thy law it is my meditation
all the day
and then again that implies
what the bible says in the new testament
pray without ceasing well that doesn't
mean some kind of weird thing where
you're always muttering prayers but
you're always
inspecting everything from a biblical
perspective
you're weighing what goes on in your
life to what the bible says and that's
meditating
whether we're in some kind of posture or
not is irrelevant the first time
meditation was mentioned in the bible
isaac was walking out through a field
that had been cultivated just thinking
about god amen that's meditation all
right and i love this next one
psalm 119 verse 48 my hands also will i
lift up to your commandments which i
love i will meditate on your statutes
and psalm 119 verse 99 says i have more
understanding than all my teachers
for your testimonies are my meditation
that's powerful i mean if you want to if
you want a better education if you want
to have wisdom in whatever field of work
you're doing
if you make the bible your source of
your life he'll bless everything else
and what you brought out is so important
to meditate on the word of god is not to
rush through a surface reading is to
dwell on it and sometimes slowly yes and
pausing after each statement
just to soak it in and
and to open your heart up to what the
holy spirit may speak to your heart
and sometimes he'll give you ideas that
just blow your mind like i was studying
passion week recently
and it dawned on me all these people
were throwing their coats in front of
jesus entering jerusalem the triumphant
entry
and for some reason i saw a connection
i'd never seen before that the last
thing god did before he left the garden
when he pronounced the curse
was to clothe
adam and eve in coast of skin and
thousands of years later
their offspring are throwing the
clothing before him as if to thank him
amen for his care
in the very beginning all the way
through it's almost like god reaped what
he sowed
i really enjoy being in in the south
here i mean we moved out here probably
five years ago from from california and
you just don't
you don't see
like people writing god things on
billboards and stuff like you do here
you go into many people's homes around
here and it's like you know it's all
over the walls it's all over the it's
all over which actually was commanded to
the jedi yeah in deuteronomy absolutely
write it on your door post right under
things that's why we actually put it in
a little mezuzah now but it should be
where you can read it yeah yeah and we
we you know we make t-shirts in our
ministry and part of the purpose is to
always have these concepts on your mind
to be a walking witness to to just keep
it before you and keep that perspective
in front of you always
amen to that
well the next way of meditating
that the bible commands us to
is also found in psalm 119 which is
you could call it the meditative psalm
verse 27
the psalmist says make me understand the
way
of your precepts so shall i meditate on
your
wonderful work i would call that moving
meditation i go outside you take a walk
in nature and you look at the flowers
and the trees and you talk of his
wondrous works that's moving that stage
how adam meditated in the garden he
walked with god amen noah walked with
god
enoch walked with god abraham walked
with god they took walks where they
would
if it was nighttime look up at the glory
of the
sky and then millions of stars the
heavens declare the glory of the lord
and the firmament shows his handiwork
so
that's one way of meditating on his
wonderful works if you see the magnitude
of the cosmos you see the
majesty of the one who made it all
happen
and it just gives you a connection now
unfortunately the heathen don't
differentiate between
the creation and the creator and
sometimes they end up worshiping the sun
worshiping the moon
worshiping different facets of creation
instead of the creator who made it uh
yeah when you see creation through the
lens of of true christianity you see the
symbiotic relationships that god made
the bees to the flower that you know
spread the pollen around you can see the
fingerprint of god and you sit and you
think about that and you go you know
what this is this is neat god made us to
be able to work together to bless other
people and you have this relationship i
bless you you bless them you know and
you keep this moving around and it's all
selfless and everything is sacrificing
for the life of something else yeah
which which doesn't go at all in any
sort of survival of the fittest type you
know mentality at all like you know i'm
just gonna take what what is mine and
you know you can see that if you really
take a slow down look at god's creation
you see his fingerprint
amen and when you think of the microcosm
not only the macrocosm right
but the invisible world right the
genetic invisible world the amazing
genius
of the genetic code and everything
that is living or
the atomic world the molecular world how
god puts all of that together and
creates different substances
it should turn a atheist scientist into
a believer right and it's amazing that
they don't recognize it and actually i
have read different accounts of
scientists who have been converted to
christianity who said when the genetic
code was discovered it just changed
their world
there's a documentary that's made by
illustra media and it's called unlocking
the mystery of life and it's about a
group of quote
atheist scientists that got together
because they were all scientists in
different fields of
science
but they all had questions that they
could not answer and they got together
at this
beach house i think in california in
southern california and they said we
just want to be able to talk and ask
questions without being
condemned and silenced and they got
together for that weekend and when it
got finished they made this film and
they said there's a creator there's no
way you can deny it and they were
finding it and they showed specifically
dna
and the human genome what happens inside
there's got to be a designer
you can go down the road all day long
and blow up piles of rock and it's not
going to make it you're never going to
fall into an order right it's not going
to all of a sudden construct a house
or a a library filled with books i think
it was illustria that said you know if
you took a bucket of parts that make up
a car and you just tossed it in the
garage that would be the equivalent of
you thinking that it just randomly came
together that's exactly you could never
toss that many parts up into the garage
and out would come a car but the
probability is is there obviously but
it's you know
trillion
yeah so minute that it wouldn't even be
a reasonable
another similar scripture is psalm 145
verse 5
i will meditate on the glorious splendor
of your majesty amen
and on your wondrous works and i think
sometimes
that would mean the works of god
in the realm of time not just the works
of creation and so how do i meditate on
his works it's not some weird esoteric
formula that you follow is just
pondering the greatness of those things
in a prayerful worshipful mode
and when you're in prayer think about
the cross
think it's not mindlessness
it's actually really mindfulness what's
called mindfulness in buddhism is really
mindless
because it's an attempt to empty your
mind of thought but instead we're
pondering his word and i like to remind
myself of what god's done
in
our family's lives the miracles he's
worked my my son was a toe walker till
he was about six years old
he never walked without walking on his
toes we finally in desperation took him
to an orthopedic surgeon who who said
the tendons in the back of his feet are
too short
and
there's no way we can deal with it
unless we clip them and then he has a
50-50 chance of either being a crippled
the rest of his life or they may grow
back longer
i said i'm not willing to take that much
of a chance amen and so a couple of
weeks later i was in a ministerial
conference and i asked two or three
pastors
and ministers evangelists to pray with
me and we prayed over my son for about
20 minutes
and claimed the promises with god with
his stripes you were healed the prayer
of faith shall save the sick and the
lord shall raise him up they shall lay
hands on the sick and they shall recover
all the promises like you said of god's
word and prayed over him i set him down
on the floor and he walked flat-footed
and has never walked on his toes like
that how long are you crazy so i love to
remind myself of that yeah when i have a
physical problem and saying hey god you
did it then
you're the same yesterday today in
prayer amen so that's part of meditating
on his wondrous works
because we're too prone to forget right
and we need to remind ourselves what god
already has done in our lives and that
he can do it again that he can do it
again absolutely beautiful so we
meditate on god's works and we meditate
on his nature and that's contained in
psalm 145
that i will meditate on the glorious
splendor of your majesty i think about
what a loving god is i think about but
again it involves thinking meditating
and thinking are not separate from each
other right do you know what's beautiful
the word god in hebrew is elohim which
means the mighty one be still and no i
can do this i mean what's impossible for
man there's nothing impossible for me
and and what's so
relevant to this particular passage
because it starts out with come behold
the works of the lord what desolations
he has made in the earth he makes wars
to cease unto the end of the earth he
breaks the bow he cuts the spear and
thunder he burns the chariot in the fire
okay
well there's a related passage to that
in isaiah's writings and i believe one
other prophet
said nation shall not lift up sword
against nation they shall beat their
swords into plowshares from their
spirits into pruning hooks nations shall
not lift up sword against nation neither
shall they learn war anymore
well that's chiseled in the concrete
outside the united nations building in
new york as if to say that's the place
from which this will be accomplished
but worldwide unity and harmony is not
going to be accomplished through the
united nations
quite the opposite it has to happen
inside of each of us what is spoken
before that scripture in isaiah says out
of jerusalem
the word of the lord will go forth
and so when the king of kings reigns in
jerusalem and the word of the lord goes
forth from jerusalem
that's when nations shall not lift up
sword against nation amen let me let me
share something and this i don't want to
go off track but what you just said
you know in daniel chapter 9
listen to what he says
and this is just verse 16 through 19.
i'm just going to highlight
daniel is praying and he says o lord
jehovah yahweh
according to all thy righteousness i
beseech thee let thine anger and thy
fury be turned away from
thy city jerusalem
thy holy mountain
when you get down to verse 19 it says o
lord hear
o lord forgive o lord hearken and do
defer not for thine known sake o my god
for thy city and thy people are called
by thy name
and i'm not saying that jerusalem over
in the middle east isn't going to have a
huge role but on a personal level
jerusalem is us
we are
we are we are mount zion we are where
god dwells so when he says i'm going to
do this for jerusalem
and it says the word of the lord is
going to proceed from jerusalem he also
says and i thank isaiah he says i have
put my word in you and it will not
depart meaning it won't cease from
coming out of your mouth nor the mouth
of your shoulder
nor the mouth of your children's
children from henceforth forever yeah i
like that i like that
i want to just before you move on real
quick um you had brought up something
that that you talked about the
mindfulness is emptying your mind
i think that's a dangerous thing to do
as well because we know we are vessels
right we are to be filled with the holy
spirit if we're not
and you're an empty vessel then just
like the story that that jesus told you
know in the unclean spirit in matthew 12
that's a good point
the unclean spirit went out trying to
find rest he can't find any so he goes
back to return to the man see what see
what how this man is and he finds his
house empty goes out and gets seven more
unclean spirits and he comes in he's
worse off than he was before i think
there's a danger of emptying the self
not feeling it you know what i mean and
and that whole emptiness that's in the
east
that i i you hear that a lot well that
the empty mind which especially in zen
buddhism and chant buddhism that's the
whole goal but what they don't tell you
in the beginning is you're emptying the
driver's seat of you so that another can
take the driver's seat you become the
passenger or the one in the backseat
something else begins controlling you
and a lot of the masters in the martial
arts they enjoy that because they say i
went out there to fight and i was not
control i didn't even have to think
about what to do with my hands and my
feet they were acting on their own
i was watching as if i was a bystander
but then they get the praise which the
devil knows man likes
well you know what
i run a publishing company called deeper
revelation books
and i published a book for a lady who
was
a transcendental meditation teacher
before she became a christian oh wow and
she was back in the latter 60s and 70s
when she studied personally under
maharishi mahashyogi
and in her book authentic enlightenment
and her testimony is on our our
comparative religion website too we have
a website
thetruelight.net
and her testimony is there
and
she
said that
some of the students approached the
maharishi
and asked him
when they were meditating if they
contacted spirits
how were they to react and he said oh
welcome them in oh wow welcome them in
and so uh
that's pr that's pretty scary yeah that
is scary because uh that's asking for
insanity yeah and she actually goes into
an account uh vail carruth is her name
and her book is authentic enlightenment
and she goes into an account about how
some people did have severe
mental issues
because of spending hours and hours and
hours chanting these mantras and opening
themselves to whatever they encountered
in the silence so
it's not just a matter of what's right
doctrine and what's wrong doctrine it's
what's safe and what's dangerous
i don't think any true christian
born-again christian though should fear
sitting in a prayerful
place maybe in your living room or your
bedroom sitting in an easy chair or
kneeling
and reading the bible and pondering the
meaning of it and pausing from time to
time because
what father gives his child a stone if
he asks for bread right jesus said that
and so also he's going to give the true
experience of the holy spirit to those
who ask amen and so we shouldn't be
afraid
of approaching god with a meditative
kind of mindset but do it in the right
way that's right all right the last way
the bible talks about meditating is on
god's names
and we find that in malachi chapter 3
verse 16
then those who feared the lord spoke to
one another and the lord listened and
the lord heard them
so a book of remembrance was written
before him for those who fear the lord
and who meditate on his name the king
james version says who think upon his
name which is basically the same thing
so the name of the lord is a strong
tower and the righteous run into into it
and are saved proverbs 18 10.
and so
that leads me to believe when you talk
about the name of the lord you're
talking about a composite name
my name is actually made up of five
parts
i don't use the word reverend
because the only time it's found in the
bible is in reference to god
but legalistically i'm called a reverend
so
reverend michael richard christopher
shree i have two middle names because i
was raised catholic and you take the
name of a patron saint
during
the ritual of confirmation and you pray
to that saint the rest of your life and
i did
appeal to christopher to pray in my
behalf for several years until the pope
released a statement that he never
existed and all my prayers went up in
smoke
i said from now on i'm going to the head
man
amen that's my complete name my name
singular is made up of five parts a
title and four names
and god's name singular is made up of a
multiple
number of
titles and names
like the titles he's the beginning and
the end the first and the last the alpha
the omega the author and finisher of our
faith the great shepherd the good
shepherd the chief shepherd of our souls
he's referred to
as the bride and morning star he's
referred to as the root and the
offspring of david the resurrection and
the life the door to the sheepfold
he is i am that i am king those are all
wonderful names amen yeah names are very
descriptive and when you read the
biblical names like daniel god is my
judge you know it's like there was a lot
of meaning that was placed in those
we don't really
have that so to say in our modern world
we don't really name people after you
know you were the one with the you know
you like to play basketball so i'm going
to call you the basketball this and that
you know um
but when you read the names of god
they're very descriptive of what he is
what he does what his power is you know
and it's like oh and and just suppose i
was meditating on psalm 91
then part of my meditative process would
be to go to the original hebrew
and starting with verse 1 it says he who
dwells in the secret place of the host
shall abide under the shadow of the
almighty almighty go to the hebrew
elsewhere most high is
el elyon yeah most high is el elyon and
then el shaddai is almighty and there's
a key there there's a beautiful little
revelation that opens up
because if i dwell in the secret place
of el elyon
and if i'm
prayerfully reading the bible then i'm
worshipingly saying you are el elyon you
are the most high you are higher than
any aspiration or hope or dream in my
life you're higher than any relationship
higher than any possession higher than
any person in this world that has my
respect or honor you're the most high
then when i make him the most high he
becomes
or he manifests himself as el shaddai
the almighty in my life but as long as i
dethrone him and put other other things
up there then he's not going to be
almighty in my behalf
you know and i come to that conclusion
and there's other names and we don't
have time you'd have to spend a whole
program sure to go into the revelation
of these names but names like yahweh
rapha the lord our healer the first
revelation he gave the jews when they
came out of egypt
the kind of the lord that heals you yeah
that's right and he healed the waters
that were under they were bitter that's
right which is interesting that jesus is
really his his
he spent more time healing and and and
ministering to people yeah than he that
he actually did just preaching messages
and he provided for healing before he
provided for forgiveness of sins he was
with his stripes we were healed that's
right the whiplash is on his body he's
also uh referred to his yahweh era or
jehovah jireh is the traditional way of
saying it which was actually the name of
the place the altar that abraham built
and the place where isaac was to be
sacrificed and god provided a substitute
in death well i'll dwell on that
meditatively as if you will and i'll
think about how jesus is my substitute
in death amen just like isaac went free
i go free
and yahweh said canoe the lord our
righteousness which is one of the most
miraculous plans that god would impart
his righteousness to us yahweh raya
psalm 23 the lord is my shepherd yahweh
rayah
so i can believe he'll guide me he'll
lead me he'll provide for me
like a shepherd that name actually is a
promise and that's like that's like
jesus in hebrew jesus yeshua or yahushua
means
yahweh is my salvation jehovah will save
yeah it's a promise absolutely and and
what's really
interesting if you go back into the old
testament many times where the word
salvation appears yes it's 13 13 is that
1344 in hebrew it's actually i don't
remember it's jesus's name it's yeshua
so like when moses said stand still and
see the salvation of the lord it's
yeshua amen so when he stood at the edge
of the red sea he said stand still and
see yeshua in other words he was saying
see jesus do his thing right right
there's i'm sorry mike there's a listen
to this this is in isaiah chapter 12
verse 1. and in that day when you have
this revelation when you when your eyes
are open to see this
thou shalt say
o lord o jehovah
i will praise thee though thou wast
angry with me thy anger is turned away
and thou comfortest me
behold
god is my salvation and that's yeshua
yeshua yeah i will trust and not be
afraid for the lord jehovah
is my strength and my song he also has
become my jesus my salvation wow wow wow
and other names like yahweh sabote which
is the lord of hosts that means the god
of an army of angels that are poised and
ready for battle
and uh and of course the name above
every name which is yeshua mashiach
jesus the messiah well all these names
are like individual blocks laid one on
top of the other and mortared together
building a stronghold or a tower of
safety and defense that we run into
and so that's meditating what meditating
on the names of god does
it helps you to get a full view
of who god is and what to expect in your
life
and that's much much different than what
a buddhist does what a hindu does what a
sufi does
or any of the other religions we've
mentioned
there is a correct kind of meditation
and it is effective and it is part of
our relationship with god amen amen i
like how you wrap that up that all these
different aspects of meditation are
designed to get us to think about who
god is
and when we think about who god is
then
we as we think about that we we see what
we want to become like
right and we see what he's trying to do
i like this person in john 17
it says and this is life eternal that
they might know you
right the only true god in jesus christ
whom you have sent that's really the
goal in this meditation is for us to
know god
and in knowing god experiencing god
he'll lead us to the path of salvation
yeah i believe that it's been it's been
really valuable to go over these things
i believe it has been a blessing for me
yep well praise god thank you gentlemen
for joining us and to our viewers i hope
you have a more clear understanding of
what the bible uh means by meditation or
what true biblical meditation is and so
we invite you to
explore biblical meditation for yourself
let it enrich your life and your
experience with god because after all
like we were saying at the end it's
really all about knowing
god and experiencing god and letting him
lead and guide in your life so we thank
you for watching this episode of led
live and we will see you next time
thanks for watching praise god
i love it i mean i can't watch enough of
this the duelist who they say can speak
with the spirits the sins will destroy
the commandments forever a suspicious
list of names prompts an investigation
at a local school and concern from
parents the death note is derived from a
japanese animated show the girl told
authorities she got the idea from a
cartoon network show
mom
i recognize that voice anywhere
[Applause]
hey
visit our brothers at school for
prophets.tv and watch from babylon to
america which has over 5 million views
on youtube alone and follow it up with
america 2 babylon check the description
below for links to this and more
[Music]
you